في كل عام كانت تبرز عده اسماء كشخصيات
كان لها دور كبير في مجالات عده ربما
اثارت الجدل في مواضيع تتعلق بها هذه
الشخصيات كانت تحت اضاءه لحظات الكبيره في
مسيرتها وعانت من لحظات حرجه في حياتها
هذا العام ثقافيه رياضيا فنيا تقنيا
اقتصاديا وحتى سياسيا كانت الاسماء
البارزه كثيره بتفاصيلها وحكاياتها التي
دفعتها لتكون عين الحدث هذه الشخصيات التي
اخترنا منها ما كانت الاكثر كثيرا وساهمت
برسم خطوط عريضه لقصصا استحقت واستغرقت
الكثير من المتابعه
منور الدنيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا يعني
[موسيقى]
مع الشهر الاخير من هذا العام كان ليونيل
ميسي اكثر الاشخاص الذين جذبوا الانتباه
في الايام الاخيره من 20 22 رياضيات النجم
الارجنتيني حقق حلمه حلم ملايين الارجنتين
ومئات الملايين من عشاق التانجو حول
العالم لتحقيقه كاس العالم رفقه المنتخب
الارجنتين هي صيام الارجنتين عن اللقب
العالمي الاغلى الذي استمر 36 عاما محققا
بطوله الوحيده التي كانت تنقص مسيرته
وتاريخه المليء بالالقاب وليكون النجم
الاغلى في قلوب الارجنتين كثيرا استحواذ
الراحل على قلوبي عشاق التانجو ومضيفا
النجم الثالثه لقميسي منتخب بلاده من ساحه
الرياضه الى ساحه السياسه حيث تطهى الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه على كل الاحداث تلك
الحرب التي بدات منذ الايام الاخيره لشهر
فبراير الماضي هذه المعارك الطويله حمله
رئيس الاوكراني بلادي ميرسي يصبح الشخصيه
الابر سياسيا هذا العالم فهو الرجل الذي
يا فكيف ولم يخرج منها رغم التقدم الروسي
في بلاده ليس ذلك فحسب بل تحول زنسكي الى
ايقونه بالنسبه لشعبه ولروبيين الذين
نصاروه سياسيا وعسكريا لتصبح اوكرانيا
وحربها معروسيا ازمه دوليه لم تنتهي
تبعتها حتى اليوم كل ذلك جعل منزلينز
كالشخص الابرز في 20 22 وعلى امل ان تنتهي
الحرب قريبا يبقى الرئيس الاوكراني في عين
الحدث العالمي النجم الامريكي هو قطع احد
اهم الشخصيات العامه ليس بسبب فيلم جديد
كسر الارقام القياسيه للايرادات انما بسبب
دعوه تشهير التي رفعها على طريقته بسبب
مقال راي زعمت فيه انها كانت ضحيه اسري
وراء انها تقصد الادرار بالسمعته بدات
المحاكمه في الحادي عشر ثمرات لسته اسابيع
بعد ذلك العالم حاز بوضوح
وهيئه المحلفين ايضا التي خلصت في النهايه
الى انبرريرد شوهت سمعه طليقها وقررت
حصولها على تعويضات بقيمه 15 مليون دولار
امريكي نجم سلسله الكاريبي نشر بيانا بعد
المحاكمه قال فيه انه ان الحكم اعاد له
حياته مره اخرى بعد ست سنوات من الالم كان
فيها هدفا للادعاءات الكاذبه التي ضربت
مسيرته المهنيه ما بعد المحاكمه فتحت له
الابواب مره اخرى بعد الطعام وفي العالم
فاعلن عن جوله اوروبيه مع فرقه الموسيقيه
في الصيف 20 23 كما اتفق على اخراجي فيلم
من جديد لاول مره منذ ربعي قريه ومع ازمه
الطلاق عالميه الى ازمه الطلاق عربيه في
ديسمبر 20 21 وقع الطلاق رسميا بين النجمه
شيرين عبد الوهاب وحسام حبيب بعد ثلاث
سنوات من الزواج في بيان نشراته شيرين
تقول
لكن بدايه 2000 و22
تبدا الدراما سلسله من الجدل من اول العام
لاخره فتاره تتهم شيرين طليقها بانه اشهر
مسدس في وجهها تاره اخرى تدلب تصريحات
ناريه ضده تتهموه بالاعتداء عليها خلال
اتصال هاتفي ومره اخرى تقبل يد طبيبها
نفسي على المسرح في احدى حفلاتها بعد ذلك
تنشر شيرين مبهما وتقول من جديد انها تكن
كل الاحترام لحسام حبيب وتنازل عن كافه
قضيه لكن هل انتهت قصتنا هنا لا تفاصيل
جديده عن تعاطي شيرين وحسام حبيب مخدرات
قبل ان تدخل 20 مستشفى النفسي للعلاج وبعد
تعاطفا عربيا واسع مع قصتها تصدق شيرين
جمهورها بعقرارها على حسام حبيب من جديد
مقلب قطاعا كبيرا من جمهورها عليها وتسبب
حتى في دعوات تطالب بمقاطعه اعمالها
على الجانب التقني والاقتصادي وفي سباق
الجدل وتصريحاته يفوزوا حتما الى المسك
الذي لم يمر يوما في 20 22 دون ان يكون
محور احاديث العلم قربما الفوضى التي حدثت
قبل وبعد استحواثه على تويتر سببا اساسيا
في هذا الزخرف الملياردير يقدم عرضا
الاستحواذ على تويتر الماضي ويقبل تويتر
العرض فيتراجع ماسك عن الصفقه وذلك بحجه
انا مسؤوليته لم يتعاونوا في الكشف عن حجم
الحسابات الوهميه تويتر
تسلم لكن مع اقتراب المحاكمه يعيد ماسك
تقديمه يستحوذ على المنصه في اكتوبر ليبدا
فصلا جديدا من التخبط والانتقدات اكثر من
نصف موظفيا منصه يقيل مهندسين الموقع
الذين ينتقدونه ويفرد رسوما على علامه
التوثيق الزرقاء او خدمه تويتر
اذا كان يجب عليه التنحي عن منصبه كمديرا
تنفيذي لت رغم التعهد باحترام النتائج
يصوت الناس نعم لكن يبقى في منصبه على اي
حال وخارج تويتر فقد ماسك لقد اغنى رجل في
العالم بعد ان خسرت تسلا نحو 40 مليار
دولار من قيمتها السوقيه لتصل الى ما دون
النصف تريليون دو